voilà les trois principes de la
stratégie nationale à partir du 11 mai
sa mise en oeuvre va reposer sur le
triptyque protéger tester isolé à la
sortie du confinement
nous serons en capacité de massifier nos
tests nous nous sommes fixé l'objectif
de réaliser au moins 700 mille tests
virologiques par semaine 11 mai si allah
proche du 11 mai disons jeudi 7 mai il
apparaissait que le nombre de nouveaux
cas journalier n'était pas dans la
fourchette prévue que nous ne parvenions
pas à casser les trop nombreuses chaînes
de contamination alors nous devrions en
tirer les conséquences
je le dis aux français si les
indicateurs ne sont pas au rendez vous
nous ne déconfit n'auront pas le 11 mai
où nous le ferons plus strictement la
direction générale de la santé et santé
publique france ont établi trois
ensemble de critères permettant
d'identifier les départements où le
déconfinement doit prendre une forme
plus stricte soit que le taux de cas
nouveaux dans la population sur une
période de sept jours reste élevé ce qui
montrerait que la circulation du virus
reste active soit et le deuxième
ensemble de critères que les capacités
hospitalières régional en réanimation
reste tendue
soit c'est le troisième ensemble de
critères que le système local de test et
de détection des chaînes de
contamination ne soit pas suffisamment
prêt ces indicateurs leurs lectures
seront cristalliser le 7 mai afin de
déterminer quel département bascule le
11 mai dans la catégorie disons rouge
circulation est levé vers circulation
limitée
nous proposons une réouverture très
progressive des maternelle et de l'école
élémentaire à compter du 11 mai partout
sur le territoire et sur la base du
volontariat
dans un deuxième temps
à compter du 18 mai mais seulement dans
les départements où la circulation du
virus est très faible
nous pourrons envisager d'ouvrir les
collèges en commençant par les classes
de 6e et de 5e nous déciderons fin mais
si nous pouvons réouvrir les lycées en
commençant par les lycées professionnels
les classes ouvriront dans des
conditions sanitaires strictes pas plus
de 15 élèves par classe une vie scolaire
organisée autour du respect des règles
barrière de mesures d'hygiène strictes
et de la distribution de gel
hydroalcoolique tous les enseignants et
encadrants des établissements scolaires
recevront des masques qu'ils devront
porter quand ils ne pourront respecter
les règles de distanciation le port du
masque est prohibé pour les enfants en
maternelle il n'est pas recommandé
compte tenu des risques de mauvais usage
à l'école élémentaire mais l'éducation
nationale mettra des masques pédiatrique
à disposition des directeurs d'école
pour les cas particuliers par exemple si
un enfant présentait au cours d'une
journée des symptômes le temps que ses
parents viennent le récupérer
enfin nous fournirons des masques aux
collégiens qui peuvent emporter et qui
n'auraient pas réussi à se procurer le
port du masque pour les collégiens étant
obligatoire un intense travail de
préparation doit avoir doit avoir lieu
dans chaque académie afin que nous
puissions préparer cette rentrée
évidemment très particulière les crèches
seront règle également réouverte
l'accueil par groupe de 10 enfants
maximum sera possible avec la
possibilité d'accueillir plusieurs
groupes de dix enfants
si l'espace le permet et si les
conditions sont réunies pour que les
groupes ne se croisent pas cette
réduction des capacités posera au moins
dans un premier temps la question des
priorités d'accueil des crèches
accueillent déjà les enfants selon des
critères économiques et sociaux et il
n'appartient pas à l'état de définir ces
critères à la place les gestionnaires le
port du masque grand public sera
obligatoire pour les professionnels
la petite enfance puisque les règles de
distanciation physique ne peuvent pas y
être appliquée bien sûr bien sûr il n'y
aura pas de port du masque pour les
enfants de moins de 3 ans le
déconfinement doit aussi permettre la
reprise de la vie économique
pour cela il faut réorganiser la vie au
travail le télétravail doit être
maintenue par tous est possible au moins
dans les trois prochaines semaines
je le demande avec insistance aux
entreprises nous en avons mesuré depuis
la mi mars le déploiement massif
personne n'en ignore les contraintes
mais celui ci doit se poursuivre pour
limiter le recours aux transports
publics pour limiter plus globalement
les contacts il n'ya pas sur ce sujet un
avant et un après on se bat pour les
personnes qui ne pourront pas
télétravail et la pratique des horaires
décalés dans l'entreprise doit être
encouragé les commerces ouvriront
également à compter du 11 mai tous sauf
les cafés restaurants pourront ouvrir à
compter du 11 mai les marchés pour
lesquels l'interdiction est aujourd'hui
la règle et l'autorisation l'exception
seront en général autorisé sauf si les
maires ou les préfets estiment qu'ils ne
peuvent être organisées dans des
conditions qui permettent de respecter
les gestes barrières et la distanciation
fils car si les commerces vont rouvrir
chacun d'entre eux devra respecter un
cahier des charges strict limitant le
nombre de personnes présentes en même
temps dans le magasin en organisant les
flux afin de faire respecter la règle de
la distance minimale d'un mètre par
personne sans contact autour d'elle
s'agissant du port du masque le port du
masque grand public sera recommandée
pour les personnels et les clients
lorsque les mesures de distanciation
physique ne peuvent être garantis un
commerçant pourra subordonnés l'accès de
son magasin au port du masque
les transports sont pour une bonne part
un dispositif clé pour la reprise
économique
mais le respect de la distanciation
physique les des gestes barrières
il est particulièrement difficile nous
allons prendre deux séries de décision
d'abord remonter au maximum l'offre de
transports urbains 70% de l'offre de la
ratp sera disponible le 11 mai et nous
devons remonter rapidement à l'offre
nominal ensuite faire baisser la demande
en favorisant le télétravail je les dis
en étalant les horaires je les dis en
demandant aux français de considérer que
les transports aux heures de pointe
doivent être réservées à ceux qui
travaillent le port du masque sera
rendue obligatoire dans tous les
transports métro comme bus et les
opérateurs devront au moins pour les
trois semaines à venir
s'organiser pour permettre même dans le
métro de respecter les gestes barrières
comme vous le savez nous demanderons à
nos aînés de continuer à se protéger il
faut qu'ils respectent des règles
similaires à la période de confinement
en se protégeant en limitant leurs
contacts et donc leur sortie tout cela
sur le principe de confiance et de
responsabilité comme l'a annoncé le
président de la république il n'y aura
pas de contrôle pas d'attestation de
sortie pour les plus âgés d'entre nous
mais je demande aux personnes les plus
âgées les plus fragiles de la patience
les visites privées quand elles
reprennent doivent être entourés de
précaution comme les sorties
il nous faut éviter les rassemblements
qui sont autant d'occasions de
propagation du virus
les rassemblements organisés sur la voie
publique ou dans des lieux privés seront
donc limitées à 10 personnes
la vie sociale va reprendre donc mais là
encore progressivement
je voudrais d'abord commencé par dire ce
qu'il sera à nouveau possible de faire
il sera à nouveau possible de circuler
librement sans attestation sauf comme je
les dis pour les déplacements à plus de
100 km du domicile qui ne seront
possibles que pour un motif impérieux
familiales ou professionnelles
il sera possible les beaux jours et dans
de pratiquer une activité sportive
individuelle en plein air en dépassant
évidemment la barrière actuelle du
kilomètre et en respectant les règles de
distanciation physique il ne sera
possible ni de pratiquer du sport dans
des lieux couverts ni des sports
collectifs ni des sports de contact les
parcs et jardins
si essentiel l équilibre de vie en ville
ne pourront ouvrir que dans les
départements où le virus ne circule pas
de façon active et fameux département
vert par mesure de précaution les plages
resteront inaccessibles au public au
moins jusqu'au premier jour s'agissant
des activités culturelles
parce qu'ils ne peuvent plus fonctionner
facilement reste parce qu'ils peuvent
fonctionner plus facilement pardon en
respectant des règles sanitaires
les médiathèques les bibliothèques les
petits musées si important pour la vie
culturelle de nos territoires pourront
rouvrir leurs portes dès le 11 mai a
contrario les grands musées qui attire
un grand nombre de visiteurs hors de
leur bassin de vie les cinémas les
théâtres et les salles de concerts où
l'on reste à la même place dans un
milieu fermé ne pourront pas rouvrir les
salles des fêtes les salles polyvalentes
resteront également fermée jusque à
cette marche du 2 juin